[Musique]
bonjour à tous ce que vous allez voir
c'est c'est ma génération c'est ma
révolution
alors aujourd'hui c'est vrai que je
considère que jouir de la vie s'en
soucier des conséquences sur la planète
c'est un acte que je considère comme
égoïste et criminel alors vous allez me
dire fuller s'en va dans des trucs on a
un constat qui est fait aujourd'hui
c'est que mes grands parents ont fait
une première révolution industrielle
mes parents ont fait une révolution
industrielle qui est la seconde et donc
on voit des choses qui ce qui chagrine
machine à vapeur charbon on considère
aujourd'hui que tout ça oulala c'est
puis bon on considère aujourd'hui que le
pétrole le gaz ou là là c'est une
catastrophe
alors la troisième révolution
industrielle c'est la nôtre c'est notre
génération et je dis oh là là je suis
allé en chine j'ai eu cette chance
d'aller en chine au mois d'août et je me
suis rendu compte de quelque chose qui
m'a assez surpris c'est cette masse de
gens qui se baladent avec des masques
sur le visage
à tel point que moi j'en ai pas mis donc
tous les soirs quand je rentre et je
comprenais pourquoi il en mettait est
donc là c'est une photo de 2012 de pékin
ok vous avez vu cette masse ce nuage
c'est juste rien parce que un an après
c'est comme ça alors je me dis mais on
fait quoi là vous allez me dire ouais
bon ok c'est une grosse vie aura les
mêmes photos environnement m naturel en
un an après même chose au hockey
donc on les compare on met tous ensemble
et là on fait un constat sur une année
sur une année il s'est passé ça alors là
on va me dire ouais c'est bon c'est la
chine ils sont 1 3 milliard c'est normal
chez nous ça n'arrive pas connaissait ce
village et que ça petit tour et puis
c'est paris alors oui là il ya quatre
ans qui séparent ces photos et je peux
entendre et comprendre qu' il y en a une
qui a été fait en août
et puis on a une qui a été fait
bizarrement en mars et donc c'est
peut-être pas vraiment de la pollution
c'est peut-être juste des effets de
brume de hockey alors maintenant
apprendre des chiffres on revient deux
mille ans en arrière comme on assomme
tout la possibilité de vivre environ 80
à 100 ans et on se rend compte de quoi
avait c'est bizarre 1780 la première
révolution industrielle 1880 la seconde
1980 la troisième le pic qui est là en
2000 années il ne s'est jamais créé
alors cette troisième révolution
industrielle le numérique puisque les
autres bombes à jean connaît aujourd'hui
les effets néfastes
c'est quoi aujourd'hui l'empreinte du
numérique sur notre planète l'empreinte
d'internet c'est simple c'est plus de
1000 térawatts heure c'est à dire
l'équivalent de 40 centrales nucléaires
à titre d'information en france on
dispose de 19 centrales
la france n'est pas capable d'alimenter
la totalité de l'internet mondial
ça correspond à quoi bon tu peux plus
que 600 millions de tonnes de co2 soit
l'équivalent du trafic mondial aérien
ok alors maintenant bon ça c'est des
chiffres machin ça sort d'internet
google on en parlait tout à l'heure et
bien votre usage à vous quand vous
envoyer un petit mail
alors le petit mail à deux pièces
jointes up 3 grammes de co2 à je vais
mettre une petite pièce jointe 50
grammes de co2 ça commence à en faire
194 milliards de mails en 2014 à un
moment ou un autre c'est 3 millions
d'automobilistes son équivalence allez
une petite recherche sur google c'est
cool 0,25 g de co2 le nombre de
recherches aujourd'hui
et quand on regarde sans recherche et
ben c'est l'équivalent de du repassage
d'un tee shirt en termes d'émissions de
carbone en termes de consommation
électrique et je vais aller sur youtube
même chose et je vais aller sur facebook
même chose et je vais aller sur twitter
un des tweets 500 millions oz est cool à
10 tonnes de co2 c'est juste excellent
c'est une super et puis bon je vous fais
pas l'état de tout ce qui existe comme
autre site et à s'achever à dos et une
chose aujourd'hui on est 3 5 milliards
d'utilisateurs dans dix ans on sera 5
milliards dans 20 ans on sera 9
milliards waouh
waouh hu alors j'ai voulu quand même
vous dire que j'avais analysé ma propre
consommation pour cet événement et ben
mes petites recherches ces trois grammes
mon petit ordinateur et mon petit
téléphone portable ces trois grammes
les 50 g de co2 pour mes petits échanges
de mails mais les 350 grammes pour venir
avec une voiture électrique
je vous raconte pas avec un diesel soit
452 4 106 grammes de co2 pour cette
présentation
maintenant je vais vous dire une chose
c'est que l'on sait hans steiner disait
ces personnes qui savent ont le devoir
d'agir
donc maintenant vous êtes tous au
courant
vous allez repartir c'est à pied et vous
éteignez vos smartphones on va faire ça
pour qui pour quoi quoi qu'on en dise il
ya nos enfants qui nous pose une
question c'est que tu crois que les
adultes ont remis la planète en état
quand on va leur rendre quelque part
moi je vais leur dire oui parce que tout
ce que vous avez vu là aujourd'hui ça
devient quelque chose d'extraordinaire à
la pollution mais ce qu'on va en faire
et donc lavoisier disait rien ne se perd
rien ne se crée tout se transforme
donc on va faire une seule une chose
puisqu'on n'a pas réussi à le faire sur
la première on n'a pas réussi à le faire
sur la deuxième révolution
bah on va le faire sur la troisième
révolution et je ne peux pas concevoir
que notre génération qui a sa révolution
industrielle ne puisse pas faire quelque
chose de virtuel avec alors qu'est ce
qu'on va faire un petit smartphone ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui l'économie
circulaire c'est à dire qu'est ce qu'on
va faire de ces données à quoi elles
vont servir
comment on va les transformer et
qu'est-ce qu'elle génère au delà de ce
que je vous ai dit du co2 enfin voilà
enfin tout ce que vous avez pu voir
avant eh ben c'est de la chaleur est
aujourd'hui regardez sur huit années on
est passé de 12 1 fournisseur de chaleur
que j'appelle internet de quelques
kilowatts à quasiment 30 kilowatts par
système aujourd'hui on a compris une
chose c'est que tous les constructeurs
de systèmes d'information de serveurs
ont compris qu'il fallait modifier la
construction de ces machines et donc
nous avons aujourd'hui la capacité à
diviser par deux la consommation de la
totalité de ses machines selon des
procédés une chose qui est exceptionnel
dans notre région il caille donc on a
besoin de quoi de chauffage et un espèce
de truc physique qui paraît être
intéressant donc est ce qu'on va faire
il est clair qu'aujourd'hui vous voyez
dans la zone bleue foncée se sont tous
toutes les zones qui potentiellement
sont adaptés 1 pour refroidir un système
d'information et c'est bizarre dans
cette zone y en a besoin de chaud
fages alors comment on n'a pas compris
depuis bien longtemps qu'il pouvait
avoir une espèce d'interaction entre un
système d'information internet est un
besoin de calories sur cette planète
vous allez me dire et gentille
cet été il est trempé alors quand il
fait 30 ton système ils marchent pas
hélas ils marchent parce qu'aujourd'hui
on est capable de stocker oms et stocker
de la glace fabriquer de la glace et
aujourd'hui on démontre parce qu'on a
cette capacité à produire de la glace
la nuit qui coûte deux fois moins cher
avec 16000 loi d'énergie je sais
produire 700 1000 watts de froid et donc
commence à faire des choses sympas
j'utilise peu d'énergie
je fabrique beaucoup de froid mais
serveurs ont besoin de beaucoup de froid
et bizarrement mais y'a des gens qui ont
besoin de chaud et on va commencer à
faire ce que la voisine a dit rien ne se
perd rien ne se crée tout se transforme
des projets ultra innovant aujourd'hui
tout le monde se plaint tout est cher
chauffer une piscine 24 heures sur 24
pour y aller avec 40 heures par semaine
un data center va pouvoir demain
chauffer une piscine une fosse de
plongée ce que vous voyez là moi je suis
un peu plongeurs un peu la raison pour
laquelle il ya un peu de tendance à j'en
ai marre du 7e continent pourri où il ya
le plein de plastique
donc je dois trouver des solutions saas
et une fosse de plongée en italie y 40
ce qu'on va essayer de faire c'est dans
la région c'est faire à la y 41 comme ça
ça sera la plus profonde du monde
chauffer quid naturellement c'est à dire
qu'à un moment ou à un autre
aujourd'hui je vais vous demander de
consommer de l'internet pour qu'on
puisse trouver des solutions et ses
solutions elles sont là et elles
existent elles vont nous permettre un de
produire des calories pour ses loisirs
est aujourd'hui aussi voyez ça c'est ce
qu'on faisait avant ce qu'on appelle une
chaufferie ouais super du gaz du pétrole
du charbon
non non non allez dehors maintenant on
va mettre des datacenters le datacenter
de demain
va être est il existe déjà sur ce
territoire
c'est vrai je vais me lancer mais c'est
le seul territoire équipé d'un nouveau
système de chauffage qui est produit par
ce que vous faites vous par vos usages
d'internet qui était un polluant qui
aujourd'hui va devenir un acteur majeur
et qui va permettre une première fois
d'envoyer les calories de ces machines
et vous savez le truc magique c'est que
quand chaque bâtiment aura récupéré la
totalité des calories il va me renvoyer
de l'eau froide gratuitement et on
rentre dans ce fameux cycle d'économie
circulaire et on a la capacité à dire
que notre génération
on a la capacité à comprendre un
mécanisme et à le transformer pour
qu'ils soient vertueux et demain vous
allez me dire super mais on n'a pas
réglé les problèmes des déplacements des
voitures des six est réglé aussi on a
travaillé avec la serre numérique sur un
projet qui a été les lunettes
aujourd'hui je ne déplacent plus un
technicien
aujourd'hui ils mettent des lunettes
l'air leurs mains et leurs yeux sont
dans un bâtiment et ses des équipes qui
sont chez elles qui prennent une
tablette et qui vont pouvoir interagir
directement
et si vraiment on doit se déplacer le
problème de l'automobile on va arrêter
les véhicules comme ça le truc on dit
parce que dans les calculs qu'on fait
généralement c'est que à la sortie du
magasin
si on va depuis l'extraction jusqu'au
raffinage
il ya beaucoup plus de co2 que ce qu'on
nous annonce des histoires de
calculateurs machin bref on va utiliser
l'énergie qu'on a récupéré pour
alimenter des véhicules électriques
demain ça c'est le schéma
alors je dis demain mais en fait c'est
déjà existant aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on est déjà dans cette ère
où internet va nous permettre de
produire de l'énergie du chauffage en
l'occurrence on va s'alimenter en éolien
à l'échelle d'un an et demi on va
s'alimenter en solaire ici je peux
comprendre solaire il y en a marre je
sais je suis un pur produit du drap
et on va réaliser cette économie
circulaire et donc j'ai véritablement
envie de vous dire tout ça ça existe
ce que je comprend pas c'est qu'on l'a
pas fait à la première c'est qu'on l'a
pas fait à la deuxième est que nous
subissons ces deux premières révolutions
et qu'aujourd'hui la réponse à mes
enfants à nos enfants et aux générations
à venir
c'est de leur dire ne vous inquiétez pas
continuons à faire et demain cette
planète
on pourra leur rendre dans le meilleur
état qu'il soit merci à vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]